Fue justo en el video pasado cuando empezamos
a hablar de sistemas de ecuaciones
y sobre qué eran los sistemas de ecuaciones
y en el video pasado analizábamos cómo resolver
un sistema de ecuaciones,
por el método gráfico,
sin embargo en esta ocasión lo que quiero ver
es un sistema de ecuaciones
pero analizado de una manera algebraica,
así que lo primero que voy a hacer
es poner aquí las dos ecuaciones
y la primera va a ser "x" más "2y"
esto voy a decir que es igual a 9
y la siguiente va a ser "3x" más "5y"
esto voy a decir que es igual a 20,
éste va a ser igual a 20.
Muy bien, ahora lo que quiero que recuerdes
es que en el video pasado lo que hacíamos
era tomar estas ecuaciones y ponerlas en
su forma pendiente ordenada al origen
o tal vez punto pendiente,
lo cual ya sabemos hacer,
darnos cuenta que era una recta y graficar
ambas rectas en un plano cartesiano para ver
en que punto se intersectaban,
en esta ocasión lo que quiero ver es un nuevo método,
un método más algebraico
y este método es el método de sustitución,
es decir, me voy a fijar en una de estas ecuaciones,
voy a despejar a una de estas variables,
sea "x" o sea "y" y la voy a meter en la otra ecuación,
la voy a enchufar en la segunda ecuación
y bueno, para que poco a poco te vaya quedando
mucho más claro, vamos a hacerlo.
Me voy a tomar la primera ecuación que es
"x" más "2y" igual a 9 y lo que voy a hacer
es despejar a "x" y para esto voy a restar
"2y" de ambos lados de la ecuación,
entonces del lado izquierdo me queda solamente "x",
mientras que del lado derecho
me queda 9 menos "2y", "2y" menos "2y" se van
y solamente me queda "x" igual a 9 menos "2y".
¡Perfecto!
ya tengo una expresión para "x",
aquí nos está diciendo que "x"
tiene que ser igual a 9 menos "2y",
pero como tiene que cumplir las dos ecuaciones, entonces esta misma "x"
es esta "x" de la que tengo en la segunda ecuación,
aquí tengo una expresión para "x",
"x" es igual a 9 menos "2y",
pero esta "x" es la misma "x" de la otra ecuación,
porque tiene que cumplir
ambas ecuaciones simultáneamente,
por lo tanto, en la segunda ecuación,
en lugar de poner a "x", voy a poner a 9 menos "2y"
y me queda, 3 que multiplica a "x",
pero "x" es 9 menos "2y"
y a esto le voy a sumar "5y",
esto tiene que ser igual a 20,
lo único que estoy haciendo es sustituyendo el valor de "x" adentro de mi segunda ecuación, porque recuerda,
ya sabemos que "x" vale 9 menos "2y"
de la primera ecuación y bueno,
¿cuánto es esto?
3 por 9 = 27, 3 por "-2y" es "-6y"
y a esto le voy a sumar "5y" esto es igual a 20,
lo único que hice fue distribuir este 3
adentro del paréntesis
y después voy a reducir
términos semejantes,
"-6y" más "5y" es lo mismo que "-1y",
entonces me queda 27 menos "y" es igual a 20,
¿y ahora qué pasa si sumo de
ambos lados de la ecuación -27?
Si te das cuenta,
lo que estamos haciendo es logrando despejar a "y",
¿"y" qué me va a quedar?
Bueno, de este lado 27 y 27 se van,
me queda"-y", mientras que del lado izquierdo me queda
20 menos 27 es -7 Y ahora si,
el valor de "y" que satisface ambas ecuaciones
es "y" igual a 7, si multiplico ambos lados por -1
o paso este signo menos del otro lado
me queda que "y" igual a 7 es
el valor de "y" que satisface ambas ecuaciones,
¿y cómo lo logré?
Sustituyendo encontré una expresión para "x",
la cual enchufé la segunda ecuación
y entonces ya tengo que "y" es igual a 7,
perfecto,
una vez que ya tengo que "y" es igual a 7,
qué te parece que de aquí
de esta expresión que tengo aquí para "x"
voy a sustituir ahora el valor que tengo de "y"
"y" vale 7,
por lo tanto "x" es igual a 9 menos 2 por 7,
o sea que "x" es igual a 9  menos 14,
lo cual me dice que "x" es igual a 9 menos 14, que es -5.
Ya tengo también el valor para "x",
el par "x" igual a -5 y "y" igual a 7
son los dos valores que cumplen simultáneamente ambas ecuaciones o dicho de otra manera,
el punto -5, 7 es el punto de intersección
de estas dos rectas.
Y es más, vamos a verificarlos,
si "x" vale -5 y "y" vale 7 en la primera ecuación,
me queda -5 más 2 por 7 que es 14 y esto es
igual a 9 y en la otra ecuación me queda
3 por -5 lo cual es -15 más 5 por 7,
5 por 7 es 35 y 35 menos 15 es 20,
perfecto,
cumple ambas ecuaciones.
Y este es el segundo método para resolver
sistemas de ecuaciones que quería ver contigo.
Ahora vamos a hacer otro ejemplo,
pero este ejemplo vamos a complicarlo un poco más,
porque quiero ver un problema que tenga
que ver  con un sistema de ecuaciones
que a su vez lo resolvamos
por el método de sustitución.
Así que el problema dice lo siguiente,
la suma de dos números... la suma de dos números...
esto es exactamente igual a 70...
la suma de dos números es 70
y la diferencia de estos dos números es 11...
la diferencia o la resta de estos dos números es 11,
así que tenemos 2 números que su suma es 70
y su diferencia es 11 y bueno,
la pregunta es,
¿cuáles son estos dos números?
¿cuáles son estos números?
Y bueno, lo primero que hay que hacer cuando tenemos un problema como éste, es definir variables,
es un consejo que te doy,
el problema lo tenemos de una forma abstracta,
pero cuando nosotros lo escribimos en un lenguaje matemático podemos llegar a resolverlo.
Entonces voy a bautizar a "x" como el número más grande y a "y" como el número más pequeño,
me estoy tomando dos variables arbitrarias,
así que puedes cambiar las variables
o el nombre de las variables, no importa,
pero lo importante es ponerle el nombre a las variables
y bueno,
vamos a leer la primera oración que dice,
la suma de estos dos números,
es decir, la suma de "x" más la suma de "y",
esto tiene que ser igual a 70,
la suma de dos números es igual a 70
o dicho de otra manera "x" más "y" es igual a 70
y su diferencia es 11,
por lo tanto como la diferencia es positiva,
me voy a tomar el número más grande que es "x"
y a este número le voy a quitar "y" y me va a dar 11,
que por cierto la diferencia de un número muy grande
menos un número pequeño,
me va a dar algo positivo, muy bien.
Y ahora, lo que voy a hacer es resolver
este sistema de ecuaciones por sustitución,
ya tengo dos ecuaciones con dos incógnitas
y para resolver este sistema de ecuaciones
voy a resolverlo por sustitución,
así que me voy a fijar en la segunda ecuación.
En la segunda ecuación voy a despejar a "x" y para esto voy a sumar "y" de ambos lados de la ecuación,
más "y" del lado izquierdo,
más "y" del lado derecho,
de tal manera que esto se cancela
y me queda que "x" es igual a 11 más "y" o a "y" más 11.
Ya tengo aquí despejada a "x" de esta segunda ecuación, "x" es igual a "y" más 11, ojo,
aquí ya tenemos a la variable "x" despejada en términos de la otra variable, de la variable "y".
Y bueno, como estamos utilizando el método
de sustitución lo que vamos a hacer es enchufar
esta "x" en la primera ecuación, porque recuerda
que esta "x" tiene que cumplir ambas ecuaciones,
es la misma "x" que tenemos
en la primera ecuación.
Y por lo tanto,
en lugar de "x" voy a poner "y" más 11...
"y" más 11 más "y",
esto tiene que se igual a 70...
"y" más 11 más "y" es igual a 70...
y a este "y" más 11 no lo pierdas de vista
porque este "y" más 11 es mi "x",
la "x" que estoy enchufando en la primera ecuación,
es justo por eso
que la despejé de la segunda ecuación.
Y bueno, ya tengo que "y" más 11 más "y"
es igual a 70, date cuenta que ya tenemos
una ecuación con solo una incógnita por
lo tanto esto ya está muy fácil de resolver,
¿y ahora si, qué me queda?
"y" más 11 más "y" es igual a 70
y si sumo "y" más "y" me queda que "2y" más 11,
esto es igual a 70
y si pasamos el 11 del otro lado,  lo que voy a hacer es restar 11 de ambos lados de la ecuación
y me queda que "2y" es igual a 70 menos 11,
lo cual es 59.
Y ahora, para despejar a "y", lo que voy a hacer es dividir ambos lados de la ecuación entre 2
y me queda que "y" es igual a 59/2
ó lo que es lo mismo...
20... 30 menos... ¡ah! 29.5.
Sí, fíjate bien, 60 entre 2 es 30,
pero le voy a quitar 1, 1 entre 2 es 1/2 ó .5,
entonces me queda 29.5
"y" es igual a 59/2 ó 29.5...
¡Y perfecto! ya tengo el valor de "y".
Ahora lo que hay que sacar es el valor de "x",
pero ya tengo a la "x" aquí despejada.
"x" es igual a "y" más 11 pero "y" vale 29.5,
entonces me queda 29.5 ma´s 11,
lo cual es 30...
40...
40.5...
"x" es igual a 40.5,
es decir que la solución de este sistema de ecuaciones es "x" igual a 40.5, "y" igual a 29.5
ó dicho de otra manera,
la intersección de ambas rectas es el punto 40.5, 29.5,
¿y cómo logré la solución de este sistema
de ecuaciones sin graficarlo?
Con el método de sustitución,
éste fue el primer método que estamos viendo,
en el cual hay que despejar a una de las variables
de alguna de las dos ecuaciones y después
sustituir el valor de esta variable en términos
de la otra, en la otra ecuación.
Y bueno, ya para finalizar el video,
vamosa ver si esta solución cumple ambas ecuaciones,
es decir,
40.5 más 29.5 esto tiene que ser igual a 70,
que es lo mismo que 40 más 30 que es 70,
perfecto.
Y por otra parte, 40.5 menos 29.5 es lo mismo que 11,
cumple ambas ecuaciones.